6 25 on your monday morning clark county
school district gearing up for classes
following the winter break they start on
wednesday got a great school zone
driving reminder of what's driving you
crazy viewer rob wrote to us before the
break he says hey going north on lamb
from charleston i went past three active
school zones first one got his attention
with the sheer numbers of parents
making u-turns both before after and
right in the school zone he said the
other two had u-turners too just passing
on the dangers of parents doing wrong
thanks for writing in rob you know not
only are u-turns dangerous in a school
zone they're illegal and double parking
is also a no-no of course police can't
be everywhere all the time but it is
worth pointing out that speeding in a
school zone can also get you a ticket
with a hefty price tag when those lights
are flashing the speed limit generally
drops to 15 miles an hour for a reason
those are our kids
trying to get safely to and from school
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there is something
driving you crazy at the email address
traffic 8 8 news now dot com